there's been another mass shooting in
America the United States of America is
the one advanced nation on earth in
which we do not have sufficient
common-sense gun safety laws even in the
face of repeated and mass killings
I've had to make statements like this
too many times as a country we have been
through this too many times and these
mass shootings occur against a backdrop
of daily tragedies as an epidemic of gun
violence tears apart communities across
America this is a political choice that
we make
to allow this to happen every few months
in America we collectively are
answerable to those families who lose
their levels